maintenant on va vous demander
l'impossible
l'interview s'appelle mission impossible
[Musique]
il va falloir dire du bien maintenant là
je peux essayer de dire du bien de
séverine ferrer c'est facile je sais pas
qui c'est
pas du bien c'est pas du bien doit dire
je ne sais pas qui c'est mais elle est
sûrement formidable dit
je ne sais pas qui c'est mais sûrement
formidable est sûrement formidable et en
tout cas je crois que j'ai écrit un jour
un petit truc sur elle mais elle a dû
disparaître depuis non m a dû faire des
enfants c'est sûr que c'est une très
bonne mère dit du bien de joseph staline
à ce que jo moi je je me rappelle quand
j'avais lu les mémoires d'errol flynn
qui racontait qu'il était dans un pays
des caraïbes ou un méchant blanc frappé
un petit un petit coup lee qui portaient
les paquets et le petit coup lui avait
dit tu verras un jour oncle aux jo de
punir à et je me suis dit il ya beaucoup
de prolos humilié qui un jour penser
conclut jo allait peut-être le ramener
un monde meilleur est bon que dolla l'ag
aucune mal à aucun mal à dire du bien
donc le jo du bien d'alain finkielkraut
mois il fait de la peine je pense qu'il
croit à ce qu'il dit et je pense qu'elle
est malheureusement on t'a demandé jeu
malheureusement j'ai là ça serait
pervers j'écris un type qui fait
malheureusement un énorme boulot pour la
re montée de l'antisémitisme en france
heureusement que je ne suis pas
antisémite parce que sinon je me dis les
mecs vraiment rien à un pervers doit
vous dit rien or finkielkraut parts
fiscales que tu fais vraiment monter les
tentes et les tensions communautaires en
france du bien d'oussama ben laden c'est
facile oui c'est de se dire un mec avait
le choix entre tirer des [ __ ] à
marbella avec tous ses cousins et joue
au casino qui a pris qu'à pris une voie
où ils risquent la mort tous les jours
il est dans des grottes pour un combat
mais donne malheureusement j'ai peur que
ben laden n'existe pas plus que lara
croft j'ai peur que ce soit une création
de la cia l'a quand même il a trouvé à
dire du bien c'est mieux ça qui a déjoué
le casino à marbella qui sait pas qu un
autre registre du bien de florent pagny
ça dépend du style j'ai rien contre
florent pagny il vient du peuple il a
une très bonne voie je chante new pilote
voilà tu es bien nourri le dira
et c'est pas plus qu il fait pas des
chansons plus nul que le mec était là
tout à l'heure ouais du tu parles de
coolio non rouge et rosé non mais je les
mélange tous moi j'aimerais du bien de
george bush
je pense que le pauvre il sait pas tout
quoi c'est aujourd'hui un président
américain c'est un acteur est en fait il
ne fait que des prestations scéniques et
ce qui compte c'est les conseillers de
bouche c'est les méchants je pensais les
conseillers mais je pense que c'est un
abruti un ancien alcoolique et qu'il
sait même pas où est la france et que
donc je pense qu'il n'a pas les moyens
d'être aussi méchant que la politique
qui fait tu connais le photographe qui
veulent george bush est en train de
s'enliser dans son 4 4 et un séisme à
miami et eux donc il y a il a le choix
c'est un grand photographe il fait ou la
photo du siècle mais que le mec le plus
important de la planète qui représente
le pays le plus fort de la planète en
train de s'enliser ou d'essayer de le
sauver et là il se posera une question
quelle question
mat ou brillant
[Rires]
il faudrait que j'apprenne encore des
blagues ça m'aiderait les faits alors on
essaye de dire du bien des blagues on
essaye de dire des biens de nicolas
sarkozy et bien c'est un type qui est
arrivé je crois 12 ans en france et qui
parlait pas français qui pouvait même
pas se présenter à la présidentielle aux
états unis puisqu'il faut être né dans
le pays là bas et donc ce mec c'est
sûrement avec une très grande capacité
d'adaptation une très grande capacité de
travail
il mouille le maillot comme on dit mais
je pense que ce mec l'année n'a pas
cette dimension qui me fait rarement
respectées les politiques et à dimension
gaullienne je pense qu'il pense surtout
à son plan de carrière avec la france il
en a rien à [ __ ]
la merde c'est pas les
chasser la nature du bien de votre soeur
agnès soral et ben je ne serai pas que
pour florent pagny ou sarkozy elle est
arrivée toute seule à paris à 15 ans
elle ne connaissait personne n'était pas
du sérail et elle a réussi à réaliser le
rêve qu'elle était le sien qu'était
devenir actrice donc là dessus chapeau
grande une grande grand courage une
grande virilité parce que nous étions
une merde elle a vraiment ramé elle est
parti de très bas et ça je reconnais
qu'elle est très forte beaucoup plus
tard comme moi d'ailleurs sur ce plan là
si on disait du bien qu'alain soral
matin où là où je pense que j'ai pas
besoin parce que les gens qui ont encore
un peu de
sens de l'humanité compagne complètement
été lobotomisés par les médias qui sont
une espèce de deux miroirs aux alouettes
ce disque pour prendre autant de risques
pour rien parce que je dire je vends
beaucoup moins de deux livres que tu ne
vends de place ou de disques c'est
forcément que quelque part il ya une
authenticité parce que sinon vous est ce
que je voudrais dire non est ce qu'il me
regarde en plus si j tout ça c'est que
je pense que c'est une vérité est que
cette vérité c'est celle que personne ne
dit pas ce qu'elle coûte cher et que moi
mon rôle parce que je suis écrivain et
donc ces deux c'est de dire la vérité
cachée et qui coûte cher voilà c'est mon
boulot je l'assumé vite et que je te
reconnais en tout cas les
normes et en ailleurs en allant en
allant aussi jusqu'à trop loin et et
même et parfois n'importe quoi à temps
mais en revanche on peut pas nier que tu
prends des risques et ça c'est vrai mais
attends jetterait ainsi que jésus a bien
dit
aimer les gens qui ne vous aiment pas
car il n'y a aucun mérite à aimer les
gens qui vous aiment mais moi je n'ai
absolument aucun mépris pour les gens
que j'aime pas la preuve c'est que je
passe mon temps à réfléchir à pourquoi
ils sont comme ça et je cherche à
expliquer et quand tu es dans une
démarche d'explication n'y a jamais de
haine parce que d'abord pour comprendre
l'autre aussi intéressé parce que
comprendre ça veut dire avoir en soit
c'est à dire que j'essaie de savoir qui
est ce je me dis comment peut-on être la
bonne et je me dis par exemple je veux
pas citer tous âges près de six mois je
me dis comment potes et je réfléchis
milles ce mec là ça trouve là une petite
[ __ ] il s'est fait humilier à l'école
il se fait taper il n'avait pas le choix
et moi je passe mon temps à pardonner
mais ce que je veux c'est comprendre
avant le tard de ne pas parler de
richard qu'elle s'asseye
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'institut
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux